I think the capitalism doesn't work when
the capitalists start buying politicians
and lobbying and then it becomes crony
capitalism then the government and the
capitalist team up that's definitely not
the capitalism I'm talking about because
that's that is what you call the highest
level of monopoly when a company can buy
votes and a company can buy politicians
that's when capitalism breaks down so in
order more here don't think only at the
level of personal corruption it's more
intricate how teach them are combined no
no we know that's what I learned from
Julian Assange now Google is connected
with NSA and so on and so on you know
the links are deeper our institutional
it's not just you know one rich
capitalist whatever is directly buying
but nonetheless fascinates me cow hey
some progressive I don't know I call the
progressive capitalist like Bill Gates
and so on I don't totally trust them but
they see this Warren Buffett I saw set a
couple of days ago market is great but
we need a state Bill Gates said
capitalism is great but there are things
we couldn't be left to capitalism and so
on and so on that's what I'm saying and
again it can be done not in the same way
as it was done in Sweden and the golden
era of social democracy but that's the
only that's the only direction that I
see do you think those guys even the
buffets and the gates in order for them
to protect their wealth they have to
also make sure they give respect to the
state or a house the state can make
their life a living hell so they have to
make sure publicly they they kind of say
hey stay please don't bother me I I do
think that's a very power play that the
readiness was wrong people of course but
still I don't care what their private
motives they said but their message is
important which is again market cannot
do all the job in critical moments which
now are not just
a year or two for decades State or maybe
we will get to I don't know invent some
other forms of social coordination we'll
have to play a much stronger oh one of
the things that I was my kids were
offended by your book I'm gonna tell he
was very offensive a part of your book
right okay nice one my eight-year-old my
six-year-old I read him a part of the
book they were furious with you I think
it's very well I'm gonna read it to you
it's very offensive they were upset and
they said dad please bring this up to
them there's a part in your book where
you say amusement amusement parts are
turning into ghost towns perfect I
cannot imagine a more boring and stupid
place than Disneyland what do you have
against Disneyland sir I was not
blessing
I loved good amusement parks ten years
ago
for a week Orlando Florida it was boring
everything was totally predictable
I was specific against Disneyland where
are you in Orlando
okay many times yeah Universal Studios
much more not much better but what's
much more interesting for me I'm with a
more Universal Studio Phyllis Diller
yeah I will put it like this now I will
play your game in Disneyland there is
simply not enough competition you have
there free TV in your room
and you get less stupid not even the
best the best Disney cartoons we know
are from the thirties and forties and
you don't get there all these repetitive
and so on so obviously artificial and so
on and so on so this is not against
amusement parks it's just Disneyland is
I don't get it why even you know did you
visit arrow the one near Paris now comes
it called arrow there is a Disneyland in
the suburbs of Paris oh yes but I
haven't been to it yes net one is a
little bit better
you
[Music]